THAN WHAT WAS INDICATED IN THE
TEXT MESSAGES.
>> Bret: CATHERINE HERRIDGE,
THANK YOU.
WE ARE LESS THAN A WEEK AWAY
FROM THE SCHEDULED SUMMIT
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG UN.
THE U.S. AND THE WEST WANT
NORTH KOREA TO ABANDON ITS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM.
NORTH KOREA MIGHT WANT THE U.S.
TO PULL ALL OR SOME OF ITS
TROOPS OUT OF SOUTH KOREA.
TONIGHT NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER GRIFFIN
LOOKS AT THE RELATIONSHIP AND
WHAT THOSE CHANGES MIGHT MEAN.
>> THERE IS NO CHANGE.
>> JIM MATTIS EN ROUTE FROM A
DEFENSE CONFERENCE IN SINGAPORE
SPENT MUCH OF THIS TYPE
REASSURING ALLIES THE U.S. WOULD
NOT BE DISCUSSING THE REMOVAL OF
U.S. MILITARY FORCES.
FROM KOREA
SHUTTERING ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> I WILL SAY IT AGAIN.
I'M NOT MAKING NEWS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
IT'S NOT A SUBJECT OF
DISCUSSION.
>> THE PRESIDENT TWEETED:
"MEETING IN SINGAPORE WITH NORTH
KOREA WILL HOPEFULLY BE THE
START OF SOMETHING BIG.
WE WILL SOON SEE!"
SOME SOUTH KOREANS SUGGEST SUCH
A GRAND BARGAIN SHOULD BE ON THE
TABLE.
MICHAEL O'HANLON OF THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTION SAYS SUCH
A DISCUSSION NEEDS TO OCCUR BUT
NOT AT THE SUMMIT.
>> THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE
STARTING PARTLY BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS HAD SOME
THINGS THAT MAKE PEOPLE WONDER
IF HE MIGHT BE WILLING TO MAKE
THIS KIND OF A GRAND BARGAIN.
WE KNOW THAT HE'S NOT AS
ENAMORED SOME OF AMERICA'S
ALLIANCES FOR SOME OF HIS
PREDECESSORS.
>> 24,915 ACTIVE-DUTY TROOPS IN
SOUTH KOREA.
IN THE EVENT OF A WAR, THE U.S.
IS COMMITTED BY TREATY TO SEND
UP TO 690,000 ADDITIONAL U.S.
FORCES TO REINFORCE SOUTH KOREA.
ALONG WITH 160 NAVAL VESSELS AND
2,000 MILITARY AIRCRAFT.
SOUTH KOREA HAS THE LARGEST
STANDING READY MILITARY OF ANY
OF AMERICA'S 60 ALLIES BUT EVEN
THAT ARMY IS HALF THE SIZE OF
NORTH KOREA'S CONVENTIONAL
FORCES.
THE HERITAGE FOUNDATION'S JAMES
CARA BONO SAYS IT'S CHEAPER TO
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAT
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAE
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAN
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAB
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAI
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAG
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAT
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAE
KEEP U.S. TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREAM
HOME.
>> JAPAN AND SOUTH KOREA VERY
MUCH OF THE COST OF FACILITIES
IN NORTHEAST ASIA, SO AMERICAN
TAXPAYER DOESN'T PAY FOR ALL
THIS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCED THE
LOCATION OF THE SUMMIT TODAY,
THE CAPELLA HOTEL IN SINGAPORE.
A FIVE-STAR RESORT.
THE MEETING WILL BEGIN AT